hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm Noel
Colette
Noel sit a little consider a little
closer so do you have back issues no
okay good yeah now your focus so Noel
new to the channel met her on Friday
yeah she's a great exotic dancer like
you know you tip someone enough
eventually they'll come on the channel I
am of course kidding she's a friend of a
friend so today we're checking out a
video called
the rock diet plan attempted by a real
person and I want to know well the beer
for this video because she is like super
health freak when she came to her
100,000 subscriber party she wouldn't
drink
she wouldn't smoke she wouldn't do
cocaine she wouldn't do heroin like and
I was like at least try some ecstasy she
wouldn't even do X guys yeah I know
he and grandma but I have fun she
actually has a channel it's a like a
vegan diet Channel yeah yeah it's called
dearest daughter and I'm trying to make
videos about vegan diets that are
healthy but also like easy to implement
in your lifestyle sometimes some vegan
videos on youtuber like eat the million
calories or cook of this complicated
meals like trying to get more simple and
also talk about the environmental
impacts and like other things that
aren't necessarily talked about in the
vegan community that is everything my
lifestyle is interested in knowing so
let's watch this video since she all
know about crazy health stuff not 270
pounds
I'm not a professional wrestler but I'm
also not a quitter there's no way I'm
getting through this I'm gonna [ __ ]
puke
recently Dwayne the rock Johnson
published his daily diet a 10 pound 7
meal part-time job that became the talk
of the office
naturally somebody challenged me to take
it on and not one to turn down a dare I
accepted here's how it all went down God
10 ounces of conscience to the worst all
my life have hated fish I've hated the
smell of fish I can't stand even looking
at a fish but that's how Barack lays it
out and that's how we have
my strategy throughout the day is gonna
be to work physically hard hopefully
clear up some space in my stomach for
the next meal which is of course [ __ ]
fish
if the weekly Monday morning meeting
just gonna take my food it's already
started is meal - yeah you know this
whole thing why is that the funniest
thing ever they can all sit there and
laugh but who's the one that's been at
the gym all day me straight up that
looks good maybe chicken will be better
yeah someone buys on finishing turn
three down one survivalist broccoli no
give him a pass all I have is my pride
in my reputation so if I don't make it
through its a fate worse than death
three pounds so usually I'd go outside
I'd walk around as you can see gloomy
day and NYC but that doesn't stop the
four pounds of food that are in my
stomach so just trying to get blood
flowing trying to get it moving a little
bit
I feel very insecure complex news I'm
Sean Evans and today I'm joined in
studio by Eric LeGrand the buckaroos
football player who suffered that tragic
injury in 2010 I walk out of the
interview and of course there's more
fish waiting for me he has to eat this
way because he's like the cover of men's
fitness a guy like me on the other hand
you just don't eat that much you work
out four times a week and things just
kind of like take care of themselves my
diet consists of mostly Chipotle and
bongs mo yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] puke
yeah you are I wanna see this obviously
I feel horrible just puking but in a
weird way I think it might have been
kind of a blessing because it just opens
up room for the next meal blessing who
el is great since I'm not taking a lunch
break today I guess I'll have it over
here at the gym do meals 5 & 6 free up
some space let's go
how could snack yeah I'm working through
it I'm not a quitter but I'm also not
the rock
more fish just fish and rice meal number
six it's just too much I'm brimming at
this point that's gonna go into a
garbage can but I'll get back on the
horse soon oh there he grabs a casein
protein
I respect the rod but if you had the
money that he has and the success that
he has right like would you be waking up
at 4 o'clock in the morning and just
shredding legs and just eating this
meathead food around the clock every two
hours inspect the hell out of it man
respect the hell out of doing Johnson
alright so I might not have completed
the challenge but I came pretty close
the rock has over a hundred pounds on me
and we didn't compromise a single
calorie so if you think you could do
better I'd encourage you to try I'm not
270 pounds but I'm still a beast I
guarantee you can't come close
Blanka flavor
Wow holy crap that was not what I was
expecting it that song was going to
actually eat rocks no it's really
concerned I was like oh no this person's
eating rocks anyway yeah that was a
pretty interesting video I would love to
try that one day that's a very strong
perfume it's really funny though because
I used to think I was gonna marry the
rockness it had a poster of him hanging
in my room when he was a wrestler yeah
it's funny because the rock was always
buffed but then when he became a movie
star he got like insane yeah I didn't
realize that he ate that much obviously
I'm vegan so I wouldn't be eating like
the animal products that you know and
just like the rice and the vegetables
alone including I don't think I could
eat that anyway I know I mean sure makes
them sexy and stuff but is that good for
you long term like long term it seems
like you'd be really bad for you I don't
know how much he works out like maybe
he's working out all those calories and
he needs all of that energy um I know
that I don't put that much effort into
my workout regimen at all so I don't
need like a million calories a day well
how big do you think The Rock's penises
needing that's why they call him the
rock
I mean his last name is Johnson oh
that's a good point I hope you hope he
has a big [ __ ] that's great
that's great I mean even your life even
if you're like not into big penises but
you would expect the rock to have a big
penis unless her steroids involved at
all which it didn't seem like there were
no he seems like a total fitness freak
you know yeah I get the impression the
Ross into fitness but this guy though I
really respect him for what he did there
were no excuses for this guy like what I
really liked was because when I workout
I'm sorry workout again but I'm very
much like I hate the feeling of sweat on
my clothes like I
very uncomfortable if I workout it's
like one workout shower and then try not
to sweat for the rest of the day this
guy was like working out in his office
clothes in the office and I was pretty
cool I was pretty inspired by that to
like keep going that to meets you cuz
I'm very like ah I'm not like I don't
know I need to get more on the like
doing workouts while I'm at home thing
that was a good point but what was like
it looked like he was taking you like a
rowboat and leave ya look like a long
winner that was like a upside-down
rowboat log thing yeah I've never seen
one of those before I have no idea what
that is
that's probably like the size of two of
me anyways I'm pretty sure that's a
replica of the Rock's penis I get you're
into big penises then you'd probably die
we both you hug the rocks penis at the
same time at the same time can you carry
us that'd be hot oh one thing I really
like too is that like people were
clowning on him one thing I noticed in
life is that in order to succeed at a
lot of things you gotta be willing to
let people laugh at you and say [ __ ]
about you but you got to Rhian courage
yourself and I really like that how he
was saying like I'm the one working out
all day like it might have come across a
little goofy when he said it but at the
same time I was like yeah that is the
mentality you need is that you're gonna
be living a different lifestyle than
other people but that's what makes you
successful and everyone else kind of
falls in the being an average category
person isn't going to like you don't get
critiques for being normal is opposed to
B and normal is boring I don't know yeah
neither do I that's why they both want
the wrong penis I'm not even gay or
bisexual oh maybe that's for another
video anyway guys thanks for tuning in
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out stop
you can check out Noelle's channel
dearest daughter check that out as soon
as possible and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where we're trying to get a product
placement by getting a certain amount of
followers meaning a lot less work for me
free stuff for example man I should
really prepare props they keep [ __ ]
it oh this what's now oh my gosh they're
like the best water bottles over the Fen
tier card cup holder thing it's like a
liter of water in there you got it
you got like all your hydration and they
come and colors it's got this clip so if
you like you can clip it to your
backpack there is another project it's
something similar to this actually it's
great for [ __ ] parties [ __ ]
parties in case you guys don't know
that's when a bunch of guys get together
and then they drink but it's they really
just come on the girl Noelle knows what
I'm talking about yeah yeah yeah which
is for sure yeah she's on camera right
now yeah Wow you you taught mine huh you
talk I was about to be like people come
in this and then you drink Wow that was
well played well played oh yeah that is
even better you should I still wonder
what your relationships